-Guys, it's been an incredible,
incredible NFL playoff season,
and after yesterday's
crazy games,
we finally know who will be
in the Super Bowl.
And, man,
it's going to be a good one.
You've got two underdog teams --
the Cincinnati Bengals
taking on the Los Angeles Rams.
You've got --
[ Cheers and applause ]
You've got veteran quarterback
Matthew Stafford
going up against newcomer
Joe Burrow.
I mean, it's --
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's nearly impossible to
predict who's going to win,
but you're in luck, because when
it comes to predicting things,
we have a secret weapon,
and it's puppies.
That's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ladies and gentlemen,
it's time for the
"Puppy Predictors:
Super Bowl LVI Edition."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Puppy predictors ♪
♪ Puppy predictors ♪
-Now, here's how it works.
We have one bowl of
delicious kibble
and two adorable puppies,
one representing the Bengals,
the other representing the Rams.
Whoever gets to the bowl first
will be crowned
Super Bowl champs.
Now let's meet the puppies.
♪♪
[ Audience "Awws" ]
Alright, guys.
Yeah, nice to see you guys.
Of course, we have --
hey, Ron --
we have Ron Bell
representing the Bengals.
And representing the Rams,
we have Gary Frick Jr.
Hey, Gary.
Gary, how you doing, bud?
Nice to see you.
Oh, hi, guys. Hi, guys.
That's right.
Alright, now, guys,
before the show --
Before I release you here,
I want you to listen up.
Gary, focus. Gary -- Yes.
Good boy. Wow. Look at him.
Alright, now, I don't want any
wandering or butt sniffing.
I want this to be fair, okay?
Whoever gets to the -- Gary.
Whoever gets to the bowl first
wins the Super Bowl.
Yeah, that's right.
Look at the focus.
Look at the focus on these guys.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's what I'm talking about.
That's the best
they've ever been.
Alright, whenever we're ready.
Release the puppies.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my -- Wait. Who is it?
[ Dinging ]
We don't know. We don't know.
We have no idea.
We have to run the replay.
We have to -- There's a scandal.
It looks like...
Whoa! The winner of
the Super Bowl...
[ Dinging ]
...will be
the Cincinnati Bengals.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Congratulations on the win, bud.
I'll put -- Thank you.
[ Laughs ]
We'll be right back with
Peyton Manning, everybody.
Congratulations to the Bengals.
Good job.
You did a good job.
You want to go back and eat?
♪♪